YOU HEAR US OVER HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER YES THEY CAN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILL BEGIN SHORTLY.
SECRETARY
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA ATKINS BACKER PORGES
BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTESE
DALLY DODD ALSO EGGMAN GONZALEZ
GROWTH HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO
JONES LAYERED LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
SHOW OF THOSE. PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO INNER NUMBER BUT HOW
SKI WIENER WILK. MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RSE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. BY
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. LOVING GOD AS WE
CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY MONTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY TWO
YEAR OLD BUT NOT POURED AMANDA
GORMAN HELPS US BECOME MORE
CONSCIOUS OF OUR OBLIGATION TO
STEP INTO OUR PASS IN ORDER TO
REDEEM OUR FUTURE. WE PLAY CAN
GET GRATITUDE THAT ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN ANCESTORS DID NOT LOSE
SIGHT. AND THEIR SPIRITUAL
CENTER EVEN AS THE EXPERIENCED
SYSTEMATIC OPPRESSION. PEOPLE
LIKE GENERALLY CAME THE FIRST
AUTHORIZED WOMAN PREACHER IN
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN METHODIST
CHURCH. REBEKAH **** AND TURNER
IT PREACHER WHO FOUNDED THE
FIRST BLACK SHAKER COMMUNITY.
AND SISTER THEA BOWMAN THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO
ADDRESS THE U. S. CONFERENCE OF
CATHOLIC BISHOPS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. GRACIOUS GOD WE
PRAY FOR THOSE AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHO ENLIVENED OUR
HEARTS WHICH SONG. PEOPLE LIKE
SAM COOKE A CHANGE IS GONNA
COME. MARY WILSON THE FOUNDING
MEMBERS OF THE SUPREME. MAY SHE
REST IN PEACE KENDRICK LAMAR
WHO WON THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. PULITZER PRIZE FOR
MUSIC THE MARVIN GAYE OSC
QUESTION FIFTY YEARS AGO WHAT'S
GOING ON WHICH STILL HASN'T
BEEN ANSWERED TODAY. MERCIFUL
GOD HELP US EMBODY THE FAITH
COURAGE AND LOVE OF THOSE WHO
HAVE LED US TO THIS MOMENT MAY
WE HAVE FAITH TO TRUST THAT WE
CAN BECOME AN ANTI RACIST
SOCIETY. MAY WE HAVE THE
COURAGE TO STEP OUTSIDE OF THE
SHADE AND A FLAME AND UNAFRAID.
AND MAY WE MAKE LOVE A
SPIRITUAL PRACTICE UNTIL IN THE
WORDS OF AMANDA GORMAN. WE CAN
MERGE MERCY WHAT MIGHT AND
MIGHT WHAT RIGHT THEN LOVE
BECOMES OUR LEGACY AND CHANGE
OUR CHILDREN BIRTHRIGHT A MAN.
CALIPHATE'S ARMY IN THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND-
SHE STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. SHE. MEMBERS
TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR BATES
GLACIER THE MON AND STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME SENATORS
MESSAGE FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. PARTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY EIGHTH
THROUGH THE TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO AA WILL BE
WAIVED FOR THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEWS COMMITTEE TO
MEET IN HERE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY NINE THROUGH EIGHTY
EIGHT ON THURSDAY WITHOUT FOUR
DAYS NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE.
CENTER SKINNER. SENATOR SKINNER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
YEAH. THE GOVERNMENT- ONE
MOMENT. I HAVE TO- POLICIES.
YEAH I GOT A MOTION FROM THE
SENATE JOYS VISITORS FROM WITH
THAT. I WOULD LIKE TO WITHDRAW
SB. ONE THIRTEEN THROUGH TO- OH
TWO. FROM THE BUDGET AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE IN ORDER.
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE RATHER-
IN ORDER TO SECOND READING.
SENATOR NIELSEN FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THE RICE. TWO OBJECTS
OF THIS MATTER PRESIDENT AND
THIS WILL BE MY LAST TIME THAT
IS NOT AN IDLE THREAT LAST YEAR
WE HAD I THINK SIXTY BILLS LIKE
THIS THIS IS NINETY. I'M NOT A
THREE STRIKE GUY WE DO THIS
AGAIN I'M GOING TO START ASKING
ROLL CALL AND ALL NINETY BILLS.
WE'VE GOT TO PUT A STOP TO THIS
TRAVESTY.VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SEE CENTER NIELSEN THIS WILL BE
ON A ROLL CALL VOTE. CENTER
SKINNER REQUEST AND I CENTER
NIELSEN AND- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I BAKER. BORJA FIVE BRAD. I
HAVE A- I CORTES HE FIVE DALLY.
NO DODD. THE RAZA FIVE EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ. I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG I HUESO. I HER TADO I
JONES. NO LAYERED HI LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NIELSEN. THIS
COULD GO. BUT CHAO ABOVE. PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE
ALL RIGHT I WOULD CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK. HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
BACKER. DODD. NIELSEN. BUT
CHIRLA BOGUE.
MEMBERS THE
MOTION BEFORE THE SENATE IS TO
WITHDRAW SENATE BILLS ONE ONE
THREE. TWO THROUGH TWO OH TWO
FROM THE BUDGET AND FINANCIAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE IN ORDER TO
SECOND READING. SENATOR SKINNER
ASPIRIN I MOTION AND SENATOR
NIELSEN ASKED FOR NO MOTION.
OKAY I KNOW VOTE I'M SORRY I
KNOW BUT I'M SORRY. WHICH IS
THE- YEAH- THERE IS A
CORRECTION THERE IS NO
OBJECTION TODAY TO THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. JUST ON
NOTICE THAT NEXT THURSDAY OUR
THIS THURSDAY. OKAY.
YEAH
MEMBERS WE WILL CALL. THE
MEMBERS OF OUR- MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGAIN. PLEASE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
BAKER DODD. NIELSEN I BUT
CHIRLA BOTH. DRAMA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHANGE THROUGHOUT.
ON
THE MOTION TO WITHDRAW DOES ANY
MEMBER WANT TO CHANGE THEIR
VOTE. CENTER NIELSEN. I DON'T
HAVE ANY OBJECTION TO HAVING A
COMMITTEE HEARING ON THURSDAY I
HAVE CHECKED TO BRING IT NINETY
KERRIER BILLS. I WOODS
UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT IS TO BE
THURSDAY'S VOTE AND IN A
SEPARATE MOTION AM I CORRECT.
SOME OF. YOU ARE CORRECT. SO
THAT CURRENTLY THAT THE MOTION
TO WITH DROPPED PASSES TWENTY
FIVE VOTE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS
VOTE NO. I AM SORRY. FOR
PRESIDENT. YES CENTER NIELSEN
LET ME TALK TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER.
CONFUSION THE FIRST
VOTE WAS OKAY THIS IS I'M
ASKING A NO VOTE AND I STATE
ALREADY WINE. YEAH ANY. SO I
WILL REPEAT DOES ANY MEMBER
WANT TO CHANGE THEIR VOTE ON
THE MOTION TO WITHDRAW. THAT'S
THE QUESTION. SENATOR NELSON.
MY RECORDED NO ON THE STOCK. NO
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE REPORTED AS
AN- IT'S- THE TONIGHT. NIELSEN
I DON'T KNOW. NIELSEN NOW
NIELSEN NIELSEN ITEM I DON'T
KNOW. NIELSEN I TO KNOW. SEEING
NO FURTHER VOTE CHANGES. THE
VOTE THAT MOTION PASSES ICE
TWENTY SIX KNOWS FIVE. POOPING
ON MEMBERS. INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL. 434-435-4364. THIRTY
SEVEN FOR THIRTY EIGHT FOUR
THIRTY NINE SENATE BILL FOUR
FORTY. FOUR FORTY ONE THE
FOUGHT FOR THE REST WILL BE
DEEMED READ THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
MOVING ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT ITEM NUMBER SIX
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF. MADAM PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS FILE NUMBER SIX IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF ERIN CHOI
THE CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION AND
STATE FAIR BOARD SHE IS
CURRENTLY WORKING AT SUTTER
HEALTH IS A LAWYER GRADUATING
THE UNIVERSITY OUT OF FORNEY
DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW. AS WELL AS
BRIAN MAY TO THE SAME
CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION STATE
FAIR BOARD HE WORKS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE AND GRADUATED
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY USED TO BE A WORD.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE OTHERWISE
ENGAGED BY THE APPOINTMENTS
WERE APPROVED BY A RULES
COMMITTEE ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
ON FEBRUARY TENTH A FIVE TO
ZERO VOTE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYEVOTE ON BOTH- CONFERENCE.
SORRY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BECKER. GORGEOUS I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO HI I CORTES HE- FIVE
DALLY. FIVE DODD THE RAZA. I
EGGMAN. I GONZALEZ FIVE GROSS.
I HERTZBERG. I HUESO. I HER
pI MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S AYE MIN
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF
BOTH. I PAN I PORTANTINO HI
ROTH I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
FIVE AMBERG HI HI WHAT KIND OF
SKI I WIENER. I WILK HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
BAKER. DODD. CENTER HERTZBERG
MOVES TO CALL. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SENATOR
BRADFORD. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD
RELATIVE TO BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
SENATOR BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
CURRENTLY THE ONLY BLACK MEMBER
OF THIS SENATE. A RISE IN FRONT
OF THIS AUGUST BODY TO
RECOGNIZE BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
BUT IN ESSENCE I'M HERE TODAY
TO RECOGNIZE. BURKE INTREST.
BECAUSE IF TOLD CORRECTLY BLACK
HISTORY IS AMERICAN HISTORY IT
IS WORLD HISTORY IS YOUR
HISTORY. THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES IS RICH WITH
INSPIRATIONAL STORIES OF GREAT
MEN AND NOBLE WOMEN WHOSE
ACTIONS WORDS AND ACHIEVEMENTS
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THE SUCCESS
AND PROSPERITY. THIS COUNTRY
ENJOYS TODAY. FROM THE EARLIEST
DAYS OF THE UNITED STATES THE
COURSE OF ITS HISTORY HAS BEEN
GREATLY INFLUENCED BY AFRICAN
AMERICAN HEROES EMPIRE NEARS IT
<c.cyan>OES FAR BEYOND SLAVERY IN</c>
FIGHTING FOR OUR FREEDOMS IN
SPORTS AND ENTERTAINMENT. WE
HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO SCIENCE
MADISON BUSINESS EDUCATION
INDUSTRY AND SOCIAL LEADERSHIP.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. YOU
KNOW ANYONE WHO'S EVER HAD OPEN
HEART SURGERY YOU NEED TO KNOW
THE NAME OF DANIEL HALE
WILLIAMS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO PERFORM OR THE
FIRST AMERICAN I SHOULD SAY TO
PERFORM OPEN HEART SURGERY IN
EIGHTEEN. NINETY THREE. YOU
KNOW ANYONE WHO'S EVER NEEDED A
BLOOD TRANSFUSION YOU SHOULD
KNOW THE NAME OF CHARLES ARCHER.
AND AFTER AMERICAN DOCTOR WHO
INVENTED THE BLOOD BANK AND
SEPARATING BLOOD AND PLASMA
STORAGE THIS INDIVIDUALS SEARCH
SAVE THOUSANDS OF LIVES. DURING
WORLD WAR. TWO DR KING. DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR OFTEN
STATED OVER THE LAST OVER FIFTY
YEARS AGO. FROM THE TIME WE GET
UP IN THE MORNING. AND GO TO
WORK OR GO TO SCHOOL. OUR LIVES
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY INVENTION
AND INNOVATION. OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS MORE THAN ANY OTHER
RACE ON THIS PLANET. I HAVE
CENTURY AFTER THE ABOLISHMENT
OF SLAVERY. DR CARTER G.
WOODSON. KNOWN AS THE FATHER OF
BLACK HISTORY FOUNDED NEGRO
HISTORY WEEK IN NINETEEN TWENTY
SIX THE COINCIDE WITH THE
BIRTHDAY OF TWO OF HIS HEROES
FREDERICK DOUGLASS. AND ABRAHAM
LINCOLN. AS IS DISTINGUISHED
AFRICAN AMERICAN AUTHOR. EDITOR
PUBLISHER AND HISTORIAN DR
CARTER G. WOODSON INTENDED TO
ENCOURAGE FURTHER RESEARCH AND
PUBLISHING REGARDING THE UNTOLD
STORIES OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
HERITAGE A PRIME EXAMPLE IS THE
BOOK THAT EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU WILL RECEIVE LATER THIS
WEEK THE MISEDUCATION OF THE
NEGRO. I HOPE YOU ALL NOT ONLY
JUST OPEN IT. BUT READ IT AND
REALIZE THE MIS EDUCATION THE
DR CARTER G. WOODSON SPOKE
ABOUT MORE THAN A HUNDRED YEARS
AGO STILL EXISTS TODAY. DR
WATSON UNDERSTOOD THE VALUE OF
CAPTURING THE TRUE NARRATIVE.
ALL OF OUR PEOPLE NOT JUST THE
WHITE WASHED THE CODE SANITISE
LICE THEY HAVE THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS THEY CONTINUE TO MAKE.
THE WHITE MAN THE HERO. AMERICA
LOVES A GOOD LIFE AND A GOOD
LIAR AS WE'VE SEEN FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED BLACK HISTORY
CALLING PAUL CALLING UPON THE
PUBLIC TO SEIZE OPPORTUNITY THE
HONOR. THE TWO ALL TOO OFTEN
NEGLECTED ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
BLACK AMERICANS IN EVERY AREA.
OF ENDEAVOR THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY. AFTER AMERICANS OF ALL
WALKS OF LIFE. HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY IN THE FACE OF
BRUTALITY INJUSTICE SINCE OUR
FORCED A RIVAL TO THIS COUNTRY.
THERE ARE WHITE BROTHERS AND
SISTERS FACE JUST ONE SCINTILLA
OF THE HATRED AND VIOLENCE THE
PRESIDENT'S DISCRIMINATION THAT
WE HAVEN'T TOURED SINCE ARE
FORCED TO RIVAL. THEY WOULD
HAVE BOARDED THE NINA THE PINTA
THE SANTA MARIA AND THE MANY
FLOWERS SO FAST THAT ARE HERE
TOO IT'S BEEN. THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN BACK TO THEIR HOMES OF
ORIGIN ON THE FIRST THING
SMOKING. YET AFTER AN AMERICANS
OF STATE AND CONTINUE TO SERVE
AND CONTRIBUTE TO AMERICAN
SOCIETY AT ALL LEVELS WE HAVE
FOUGHT IN EVERY WAR. SINCE THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR ONLY TO
RETURN TO BE RECOGNIZED AS
ANYTHING BUT A HERO WE'VE BEEN
CALLED EVERYTHING BUT THE SON
OF GOD. WE'VE BEEN DENIED
HOUSING WE'VE BEEN DENIED
EDUCATION WE'VE BEEN DENIED OUR
LIBERTY. WE ARE THE TRUE
PATRIOTS. OF IMMIGRANT PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE OTHER THAN OUR NATIVE-AMERICAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS
WERE ALL HERE AS AN IMMIGRANT
IMMIGRANTS. WE ARE NOT THE
ANGRY WHITE MOB THAT STORMED
THE CAPITOL ON JANUARY SIX WE
HAVE NEVER TRIED TO OVERTURN A
THOROUGH AMERICAN GOVERNMENT OR
DEMOCRACY ONLY TO MAKE IT
BETTER. ONLY TO MAKE IT LIVE UP
TO ITS WORDS THAT ALL MEN AND
WOMEN ARE CREATED EQUAL. THIS
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL AMERICANS
THE NO I REMEMBER AFTER
AMERICANS WHO HAVE MADE AND ARE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE THAT
IMPACTS ALL COMMUNITIES. IT IS
DURING THIS MONTH. WE
COMMEMORATE AND HONOR MEN AND
WOMEN. SUCH AS PROJECT ROBERTS
ALPHANUMERIC EMPIRE NEAR THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN ELECTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN. DONALD
MERVIN M. DAIMLER THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO SERVE IN
THIS CHAMBER. ON WHOSE
SHOULDERS I STAND ON AND IT'S
SOMEWHAT IRONIC TODAY I AM THE
ONLY AFRICAN AMERICAN AND I
THANK HIM FOR HIS TUTELAGE AND
THERE'S A CERTAIN FORMER
SPEAKER. AND MAJORITY LEADER
WHO PROBABLY WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY IF IT WASN'T FOR THAT
FRIENDSHIP AND TO ALLEGE A
MARVIN DAIMLER. HE WAS ALSO THE
FIRST AND ONLY PUT IN A
GOVERNOR BUT HOPEFULLY IN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS BACK TO WILL
CHANGE. ALSO THE AUDIBLE YVONNE
BRATHWAITE BURKE. WHO WAS
ELECTED FIFTY FIVE YEARS AGO AS
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN TO SERVE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND JUST LAST MONTH. OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE. SECRETARY OF STATE
SHIRLEY WEBER THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO HOLD THIS
OFFICE AT A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
YEARS AND ONLY THE FIFTH
AFRICAN AMERICAN CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER IN THE STATE. THERE ARE
MANY MANY MORE AND IT'S AMAZING
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE
THERE ARE STEEL GLASS CEILINGS
AND BARRIERS FOR ALL AFRICAN
AMERICAN STEEL THE CARD. TO
DATE WE ALL IN THIS COUNTRY
BENEFIT FROM THE RESILIENCE AND
SACRIFICES MADE BY COMMUNITY
WHOSE TO HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED AND HAVE PASSED
LACK ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION IN
THE WORKPLACE AND HOUSING AND
EDUCATION AND GOVERNMENT. THIS
IS BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS
CRITICAL FOR ALL AMERICANS TO
KNOW EVERY MEMBER AFRICAN
AMERICANS THAT HAVE MADE AND
ARE MAKING A POSITIVE
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR SOCIETY. WE
HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION AS
LEGISLATORS HELLO THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO PROMOTE
RACIAL HARMONY. AT TWO RIGHT TO
HISTORIC WRONGS OF RACIST
POLICIES IN EDUCATION. OF CARE
HOUSING IN POLICING IS NOT
ENOUGH TO SAY. YOU'RE NOT A
RACIST YOU HAVE TO BE AT THE
RACES ECAUSE THE CONTINUE TO
SAY YOU'RE NOT A RACES AND LIKE
ST I'M NOT A CHILD MOLESTER YET
THERE ARE CHILD MOLESTERS AMONG
SAYS AND WE DO NOTHING ABOUT IT
WE MUST STAND UP AND OPEN UP
OUR MOUTHS. LET US INDIVIDUAL.
AS MEMBERS OF THE SENATE NOT
IN CELEBRATION OF THIS NATION'S
HISTORY. AND EACH OF YOUR
RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS BUT MAKE A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO REMAIN
DEVOTED. IN OUR PURSUIT OF
EQUALITY EQUITY FOR EDUCATION
ECONOMICS AND SOCIAL JUSTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
A CRT. CENTERMAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I LIKE I THINK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA. FOR
THOSE ELOQUENT WORDS AND FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION FORWARD. YOU LONG
BLACK HISTORY HAS BEEN
SYSTEMATICALLY SUPPRESSED AND
IGNORED IN OUR COUNTRY BLACK
HISTORY AS MY COLLEAGUE JUST
STATED IS AMERICAN HISTORY
GOING BACK TO THE ROOTS OF THIS
NATION AND IN TRYING AS THE
ORIGINAL SIN IN OUR
CONSTITUTION. BUT WHILE WE
SHOULD BE CELEBRATING BLACK
HISTORY ALL YEAR ROUND THE
REALITY IS THAT IT'S NOT TAUGHT
NEARLY ENOUGHIN OUR SCHOOLS
OUR COMMUNITIES. WE NEED BLACK
HISTORY MONTH TO INTRODUCE
AMERICANS TO THE MASSIVE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR BLACK
COMMUNITY TO OUR SOCIETY. AND
TO CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY. IS
CRITICAL NOT ONLY FOR
REMEMBERING OUR PAST BUT ALSO
FOR BUILDING A BETTER AND MORE
EQUITABLE FUTURE. ON YOUR SITE
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE AS WE
JUST DID. WE SAY THE WORDS
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL AND
THAT'S TOO OFTEN FORGOTTEN WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO AS MY
COLLEAGUE REGARDING- A- I GUESS
SO FORCEFULLY STATED A FEW
MOMENTS AGO- I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS PROGRESS
IN THIS REGARD I URGE YOU. TO
VOTE HI. THANK YOU SO MUCH MAN
PRESIDENT. SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF US HERE AT
TEN IN THE JEWISH TRADITION WE
HONOR OUR FOREBEARS FIVE
RETELLING THEIR STORIES EACH
YEAR. PASSING ALONG THEIR
LESSONS WHILE LEARNING NEW
INTERPRETATIONS OF THEIR
MESSAGE FROM CONTEMPORARY
THEOLOGIANS. SIMILARLY A BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IS OUR ANNUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE AND
ROADS MADE BY HISTORICAL BLACK
LEADERS. WHILE ALSO RECOGNIZING
THE MODERN DAY LEADERS WHO
CONTINUE THEIR LEGACY AND
STRUGGLES THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
PROUDLY CELEBRATES BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. BUT TO HONOR THE
SPECIAL BOND BETWEEN OUR TWO
COMMUNITIES. AND TO RECOGNIZE
THE RICH DIVERSITY OF THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY WHICH INCLUDES
EXCEPTIONAL BLACK JEWISH
CALIFORNIANS. ON EXAMPLES OF
THESE INSPIRING BLACK JEWISH
ACTIVISTS INCLUDE BLACK LIVES
MATTER- CO FOUNDER ALICIA GARZA
FROM OAKLAND. A TEENAGE
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVIST IS A
CLARK FROM OAKLAND. ON BLAVITY
CLOSE COFOUNDER AARON SAMUELS
LOS ANGELES. INFLUENTIAL
WRITERS AND PERFORMERS TRACEE
ELLIS ROSS FROM LA RECEDED
JONES FROM LA TIFFANY HOW
HARRIS FROM LA. AND W. DIGS
FROM OAKLAND. IN FACT UPWARDS
OF 15% OF AMERICAN JEWS OR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND A RECENT
STUDY BY THE BAY AREA PLEASE
CHOOSE A COLOR INITIATIVE.
IDENTIFIED A 25% OF JEWISH
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE BAY AREA
INCLUDE A PERSON OF COLOR. AS
WE CELEBRATE THE AMAZING LEGACY
OF ALL OF OUR BLOCK
CALIFORNIANS THROUGHOUT THE
MONTH. I'M PARTICULARLY EXCITED
TO CONTINUE TO LEARN AND SHARE
ABOUT THE STORIES OF THOSE I IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY. LEADERS AND I
BILLS. SENATOR DRAWS A- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF AND MA'AM
AND AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ARE
RISE IN SUPPORT OF A C. R. TEN
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS
IMPORTANT TO CELEBRATE AND
REFLECT ON THE MANY
EXTRAORDINARY TALENTS
ACHIEVEMENTS CONTRIBUTIONS AND
SACRIFICES OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND ALSO REMIND US THAT EVEN IN
THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC. ISSUES
OF SOCIAL JUSTICE ARE STILL
PRESSING IN OUR COUNTRY BLACK
HISTORY MONTH REMINDS US THAT
WE MUST CONTINUE OUR FIGHT FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND EQUALITY
MUST CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
TO BECOME A SOCIETY THAT TRULY
UNDERSTANDS AND APPRECIATES THE
VALUE OF ALL HUMAN BEANS.
ALEXANDER SPENT THE MAJORITY OF
MY LIFE FIGHTING AGAINST RACISM
AND ECONOMIC INJUSTICES. THAT
CONTINUE TO DETRIMENTALLY
IMPACT CALIFORNIA AND ALL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
STRUGGLES FOR EQUALITY INCLUDE
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT
AGAINST THE BRUTAL AND UNJUST
KILLINGS OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
GENERATIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS THROUGH WORDS AND
ACTIONS HAVE MADE IMMEASURABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE SUCCESS
AND PROSPERITY OF OUR STATE AND
NATION. IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
THE GREAT WORK PRODUCED BY SO
MANY NOTABLE AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAS ALSO BENEFITED AND
INFLUENCED THE LATINO
COMMUNITY. THURGOOD MARSHALL'S
LEGAL WORK REPRESENTED THE
CIVIL RIGHTS OF ALL PEOPLE.
AMONG THOSE INFLUENCED BY DR
KING WAS A YOUNG SAYS I CHAVEZ
WHO WOULD ALSO ACHIEVE
POLITICAL SUCCESS FOR
FARMWORKERS THROUGH NONVIOLENT
DIRECT THAT DIRECT ACTIONS LIKE
BOYCOTTS. THESE ARE JUST TWO OF
GREAT AFRICAN AMERICANS WHOSE
LIFE WORKS HAD HAD HAS HAD A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE. IN HONOR AND FOLLOWING
THE EXAMPLE OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS THE IMMIGRANT WORKERS
FREEDOM RIDERS LAUNCHED ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY LED BY JOHN
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS AND
REVEREND JAMES LAWSON THEY
CONTINUE TO REMIND US. THAT
WHEN WE FIGHT FOR THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OF SOME WE REALLY ARE
FIGHTING FOR THE CIVIL RIGHTS
OF ALL OF THE HAVE THE LATINO
CAUCUS I EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE BLACK
CAUCUS AND THE CHAIR FOR ITS
LEADERSHIP AND WORK ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. SO PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
SENATORS- AS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE C. R. TEN AND
ONE THING MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
GUARDINO FOR BRINGING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION FOR- C.
SAID- BLACK HISTORY IS AMERICAN
HISTORY. AND FORTUNE AND BLACK
HISTORY OFF ACTUALLY- HERE OF
THIS COUNTRY. A REPRESENTS BOTH
THE TREMENDOUS ASPIRATIONS OF.
OUR COUNTRY AND THE HORRIBLE
TRAGEDY OF OUR COUNTRY AS WELL.
WE THINK ABOUT- FOOT TO WHAT
WAS THEN TERMED THE PECULIAR
INSTITUTION AND THAT SUCH A
PECULIAR TERM FOR THAT- THAT WE
CAN'T ACKNOWLEDGE- THE- THE
HORRORS OF SLAVERY AND- THAT
THE FORCED- IMMIGRATION OF-
BLACK AMERICANS TO THIS COUNTRY
IS THE THEIR ORIGIN STORY- TO
THIS COUNTRY. BUT ALSO IT'S A
STORY OF TRIUMPH AS WELL AS
THEM AND I- THE MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF- AFTER
AMERICANS- TO OUR COUNTRY INTO
THE WORLD- THAT ALSO NEED TO BE
KNOWLEDGE AND I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE NOTEOF THAT- CERTAINLY AS
AN ASIAN AMERICAN- BLACK
HISTORY- DOES REPRESENT OUR
ASPIRATIONS AND CIVIL RIGHTS
IT'S- OFTENTIMES IT'S- A- BLACK
AMERICANS WHO'VE. LAID THE PATH
FOR THOSE OF US OF OTHER RACES
ETHNICITIES THE FOLLOW THE FACT
THAT THIS TERM ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER- CAME ABOUT- IDEA OF
ASIAN AMERICANS AND ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS CAME ABOUT.
SIXTIES WHEN WE LOOKED ARE TO
ME LOOKED AROUND AND WE SAW
THE- WHAT- BLACK AMERICANS ARE
TRYING TO DO IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT SAID WE NEED TO
FOLLOW THEIR LEAD AND TRY TO DO
THE SAME. SO WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO WE'VE COME A LONG WAY BUT
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO. BUT
CERTAINLY- I WOULD SAY THAT-
CERTAINLY FOR MY- OWN CALLING
SOME ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY I WOULD SAY LEARNING
BLACK HISTORY IS ESSENTIAL TO
OUR COMMUNITY. TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE NEED TO GO- AS WELL AS
SOMETHING THAT'S ESSENTIAL FOR
ALL AMERICANS AS WELL SO AGAIN
I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS YOUR TEN AND URGE AND AYE
VOTES AND LIKE AND THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM GUARDINO. FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THINKING.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
BYSTANDERS THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF STR TEN
RECOGNIZING BLACK HISTORY MONTH
TO COMMEMORATE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US AS
A COUNTRY WE HAVE STILL NOT
ADEQUATELY RECONCILED SLAVERY.
WE HAVE NOT YET FULLY EMBRACED
OR ACCEPTED BLACK AMERICANS IN
OUR SOCIETY AND OUR DEMOCRACY
WHAT MORE EVIDENCE DO WE NEED
OF THIS THEN THE USE OF RACIST
DOG WHISTLE RHETORIC. TO
MOTIVATE HIS BASE THAT WAS SO
COMMONLY DEPLOYED BY THE FORMER
OCCUPANT OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
CAPITAL ON JANUARY SIX WHICH AS
WE ALL SAW. IN THE VIDEOS ON
TELEVISION WAS CARRIED OUT BY
MANY WHO CARRIED THE
CONFEDERATE FLAG. THAT YELL
RACIAL EPITHETS AT THE BLACK
CAPITOL POLICE. CLAIMED
ELECTION FRAUD PREACHING AMONG
OTHERS TO FRAUD BY BLACK VOTERS
AND WHAT MORE EVIDENCE DO WE
NEED TO SEE THE DAY AFTER DAY
THE DATE OF THE DOCUMENTS BLACK
AMERICANS FIGHTING FOR THEIR
LIVES WHEN WE SEE LARGER
NUMBERS OF BLACK AMERICANS AND
OUR LAST NEXT BROTHERS AND
SISTERS DYING FROM COPING. AS
WELL AS BLACK MOTHERS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME OR
EDUCATION HAVING WORST MATERNAL
HEALTH OUTCOMES. AS VICE CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS LET ME RECOGNIZE
CALIFORNIA'S BLACK WOMEN WHO
HAVE LED NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA'S
BUT AMERICA'S LED THE WAY IN
FIGHTING FOR BLACK LIVES FOR
ALL OF US AND FOR ALL OF US.
ISABEL WILKERSON THE PULITZER
PRIZE WINNING AUTHOR OF THE
WARMTH OF OTHER SIGNS WHOSE
RECENTLY RELEASED. BOOK CAST.
DOCUMENTS SHOW CHECK. THE CAST
THAT DEVELOP TO JUSTIFY. BUT
HAS CAST SUCH A WIDE NET THE IT
JUST CAN'T. NINE RESIDENTS. AT
SECOND CLASS UPPER LOWER CASH
RESIDENCE. AND THAT WAS USED BY
THE- TO THEIR OWN SAYS. AS WELL
AS WHITES SOUTH. AS THE DESIGN
TO THE- OF APARTHEID. BUT LET
ME READ KAMEL HERE OUR FIRST
BLACK VICE. AND OUR FIRST
FEMALE FIVE PRESIDENT IN SHE IS
SUPER. CALIFORNIA SERENA
WILLIAMS FROM CONTENT ONE OF
THE BEST ATHLETES OF ALL TIMES
WHO'S NOW FIGHTING FOR ANOTHER
NATIONAL TITLE I THINK PULLING
MAYBE AS WE SPEAK. UNLIKE SO
MANY BLACK ATHLETES SHE USED
HER FAME TO SHINE A LIGHT ON.
INEQUALITY OF BLACK MATERNAL
HEALTH AND HER OWN EXPERIENCES
WERE BOTH HURT HER INVENTION
WHILE DURING LABOR AND FIRST
HOME LIFE WAS PUT AT RISK.
STACEY ABRAMS THE WOMAN WHO
ORGANIZED AND REGISTERED VOTERS
FOR OVER A DECADE AND MOST
RECENTLY WITH A CADRE OF BLACK
ORGANIZER'S THROUGHOUT GEORGIA
AND THE SOUTH HELP TO DELIVER
US A NEW PRESIDENT AND A NEW U.
S. SENATE. THIS BLACK HISTORY
MONTH I HOPE THAT WE WILL
FINALLY MAKE RACISM PAST
HISTORY AND WE WILL EMBRACE AND
SUPPORT BLACK AMERICANS BLACK
LEADERS AND ESPECIALLY BLACK
WOMEN. THANK YOU. SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R. TEN
TECHNOLOGY CELEBRATE THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS COMMEMORATED BY BLACK
HISTORY MONTH BLACK HISTORY
MONTH RECOGNIZES THE HISTORIC
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHO IN THE FACE OF
MANY OBSTACLES HAVE NOT ONLY
PERSEVERED BUT HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN SHAPING CULTURE
ADVANCING SCIENTIFIC
UNDERSTANDING INCREASING SOCIAL
QUALITY. AND STRIVING TO MAKE
AMERICA MORE CHEST BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK BACK AT PAST
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS. AS WELL AS RECOGNIZE
HOW THEIR EFFORTS HAVE PAID THE
WAY FOR A BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR
ALL AMERICA IN FACT FOR ALL
PEOPLE. THE WORKER TRAILBLAZERS
THE PAST LATER LAYS THE
FOUNDATION FOR FUTURE DREAMERS
TO MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER
PLACE. I WANT TO CALL ATTENTION
TO THE IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WERE
AFRICAN AMERICAN SCIENTISTS
HEALTH CARE AN ESSENTIAL
WORKERS HAVE SERVED THEIR
COMMUNITIES ON THE FRONTLINES.
DOCTOR BECAUSE IN. HIS MEDIA
CORBETT FOR INSTANCE HAS BEEN
KEY TO THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES
OF HEALTH MISSION TO CREATE A
VACCINE. HER WORK WAS VITAL TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE MATERNAL
VACCINE. ISSUE NOW PHONE TEARS
HER TIME TO EXPLAIN THE VACCINE
IN CHURCHES. ON THE INTERNET TO
COMBAT VACCINE HESITANCY.
ADDRESS HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
ULTIMATELY ENSURE HER
LIFESAVING WORK ACT ACTUALLY
SAVES LIVES. AFRICAN AMERICANS
WORK AT THE FOREFRONT. OF NOT
ONLY BODILY HEALTH BUT ALSO THE
HEALTH OF MIND AND SOUL. AND
GORMAN THE YOUNGEST ANOTHER
OPPOSE IN AMERICA'S HISTORY.
CAPTIVATED THE WORLD WITH WORDS
OF HOPE SPEAKING INTO EXISTENCE
A UNIFIED FUTURE- IS PROVIDED
NURTURE NOURISHMENT TO A BROKEN
NATION SHE LIKE MANY OTHER
TALENTED YOUNG PEOPLE REPRESENT
THE FUTURE OF EXCELLENCE IN THE
ARTS. AMERICA HAS COME A LONG
WAY INTO FILLING THE NATION'S
FOUNDING IDEALS OF ESTABLISHING
JUSTICE AND CREATING A MORE
PERFECT UNION FOR ALL. STANDING
ON THE SHOULDERS OF THOSE WHO
CAME BEFORE THEM FIGURE SUCH AS
DR CORBETT AND AMANDA GORMAN
WILL HELP PROPEL ALL AMERICANS
CLOSER TO THOSE IDEALS OF
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. S.
SENATE MINORITY LEADER IT'S MY
PRIVILEGE AND HONOR TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS WORK INTO
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
GARDENIA FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
RESOLUTION. CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
HONESTY OR TEN AND I JOIN THIS
BODY AND CELEBRATING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH AS WE COMMEMORATE
BLACK HISTORY MONTH WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DEEP PAIN AND
SUFFERING THAT THE BACK THE
BLACK COMMUNITY HAS INDOOR FOR
GENERATIONS BUT WE ALSO
pBLACK LEADERS I KNOWLEDGE WITH
PRIDE THE WORK OF THE LEGENDARY
OF THE LEGACY IN THE HISTORICAL
FIGURES SUCH AS DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR WHO SERVES
AS AN EXAMPLE. OF WHAT ONE CAN
DO WHEN LOVE IS FACED WITH
ADVERSITY AND HE BASED HIS
OPINIONS ON THE CONTENT OF
ONE'S CHARACTER NOT THE COLOR
OF THEIR SKIN WE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE FREE FREEDOM LIVES
THE FREEDOM DRIVEN LIFE OF
HARRIET TUBMAN WHO HERSELF IS
GET SLAVERY TO BECOME ONE OF
THE MOST FAMOUS CONDUCTORS ON
THE UNDERGROUND RAILROAD
LEADING MANY TO INSULATE PEOPLE
TO THEIR FREEDOM TODAY WE LOOK
AT MODERN DAY BLACK LEADERS WHO
FIGHT FOR THE BLACK COMMUNITY
KNOWING THAT THEY DO SO BECAUSE
THE MANY TRAILBLAZERS THAT HAVE
COME BEFORE THEM. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THESE LEADERS ARE FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISLAND THEY
SERVE AS. EXAMPLES TO THE NEXT
GENERATION. LEADERS SUCH AS MY
COLLEAGUES THE SENATOR FROM
GUARDINO. WHO CURRENTLY SERVES
AS THE ONLY BLACK MEMBER ON THE
STATE ASSEMBLY OR SEE THE
SENATE FLOOR. SOMEBODY WHO IS
ONE OF FORTY AND ONE OF ALMOST
THIRTY NINE POINT NINE MILLION
PEOPLE. LEADERS SUCH AS
CONDOLEEZZA RICE WHO SERVED AS
THE FIRST BLACK FEMALE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO THE
UNITED STATES. LEADERS LIKE
GENERAL LEE THEFIRST BLACK
FEMALE TO ADDRESS THE FAMOUS
AMY CHURCH. LEADERS LIKE
PROMINENT BLACK ECONOMIST
THOMAS SOWELL WHO SO ACCURATELY
AND FAMOUSLY SAID AND I QUOTE.
FREEDOM HAS COST TO FAR TOO
MUCH BLOOD IN AGONY TO BE
RELINQUISHED. TO THE CHEAP
PRICE OF RHETORIC. PEOPLE LIKE
DR CARSON WHO WAS MADE FAMOUS
BECAUSE OF HIS HIS THE
MIRACULOUS SURGERY THAT HE
PERFORMED ON TWINS SIAMESE
TWINS THAT ARE JOINED AT THE
HEAD. LEADERS LIKE I'LL BE
TAKING THE NIECE OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR BECAUSE OF
THE INFLUENTIAL MEN AND WOMEN
IN HER LIFE WHO CAME BEFORE HER
LIKE HER ANKLE SHE LIVES IN AN
AMERICA WHERE SHE CAN INFLUENCE
NOT ONLY THE BLACK COMMUNITY
BUT AMERICA AS A WHOLE. LVD
KINI IN OUR PRESENT DAY BLACK
LEADER SERVES AS A MODERN DAY
REMINDER OF WHAT WHAT IS AND
HOW PROGRESS CAN MAKE A
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION. OF NEEDED KING ONE
SAYS AN OFTEN SAYS WE'RE NOT
SEPARATE RACES WE'RE ALL ONE
HUMAN RACE. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
CELEBRATE LOCAL LEADERS IN MY
COMMUNITY LIKE I SAY CROMPTON
PASTOR TO HOST THE FACT JORDAN
BISHOP BACK TRICKLE MATTHEWS
AND PASTOR JENKINS WHO BRING
LOVE AND COMMUNITY. LET IN
UNITY AND REAL SOLUTIONS TO
PROBLEMS. IN THE FACE OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THESE LOCAL LEADER
AND THE MEANT ABOVE ON IN CAN
TO FIGHT FOR MY PERFECT TEAM.
ONE WOULD THINK FOR ALL VALUE
IN LIFE IS EQUAL REGARDLESS OF
SKIN COLOR NATIONAL ORIGIN AND
ORIGIN OR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION. THIS MONTH WITH
KNOWLEDGE THE PAST THE PRESENT
THE GOOD AND THE BAD OF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH AND WE CELEBRATE
TOGETHER AS FORTY SENATORS THAT
REPRESENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK MY LONELY FRIEND FROM
GUARDINO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I RISE ON BEHALF
THE LGBT CAUCUS TO SPEAK ON
THAT S. R. TEN- I AM REMINDED
OF PEOPLE LIKE MARSHA P.
JOHNSON AUDRE LORDE. BAYARD
RUSTIN WHO GAVE THEIR LIVES AND
LIVE THEIR LIVES AND IF THEY
HADN'T I MAY NOT BE ABLE TO BE
STANDING HERE NOW- BUT I AM IN
IT BUT WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ONLY THE SOME PEOPLE RISE BUT
THERE ARE SO MANY STILL LEFT
BEHIND- DID YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
ROSE THAT GREW FROM A CRACK IN
THE CONCRETE. PROVING NATURE'S
LAWS WRONG IT LEARN TO WALK
WITHOUT HAVING FEET. FUNNY IT
SEEMS TO KEEP ITS DREAMS IT
LEARNED TO BREATHE FRESH AIR
LONG LIVE THE ROSE THAT GREW
FROM CONCRETE. WHEN NO ONE ELSE
EVEN CARED I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE BARBER LEAD SOCIAL
WORKER CONGRESSMAN RON DELLUMS
ALSO A SOCIAL WORKER
CONGRESSMAN MAN AND THEN THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF OAKLAND.
AND MOST ESPECIALLY I THINK WE
ALL WANT TO REMARK ON THE
EXTRAORDINARY. OF MISS AMANDA
GORMAN BUT IF LONG AS WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO BREAK DOWN THE
BARRIERS THAT STAND IN THE WAY.
NOBODY CAN RISE TO THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL SO AS WE AS WE
CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY MONTH
LET'S ALSO BE AS INTENTIONAL.
IN CELEBRATING. BLACK TODAY AND
INTO TOMORROW AS WE CAN HERE
PREPARE TO BELIEVE THE PATH.
FOR THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
SENATOR CURTIS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TO RISE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF US YOUR TO
KNOW ONE THING. OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM GUARDINO FOR. BRINGING TO
LIFE THIS RESOLUTION WITH HIS
OWN PRESENCE HERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR- IN HIS ELOQUENT WORDS OF
COURSE. HISTORY IS NOT JUST A
HOUSE IS IN A LONG TIME AGO
WE'RE MAKING HISTORY AS WE
SPEAK TODAY AND NOT ALL OF IT
IS GOOD OVER THE WEEKEND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH. RELEASED A PRELIMINARY
PICTURE OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED ACROSS THE STATE. AS
OF MONDAY NIGHT. THIS MONDAY
NIGHT. BLACK PEOPLE REPRESENTED
TWO POINT 9% OF THOSE
VACCINATED. FOR APPROVAL ALMOST
ALL OF THE RACIAL CATEGORIES IN
PROPORTION TO THEIR POPULATION
SIZE. WHICH WOULD BE MORE THAN
TWO TIMES A PERCENTAGE. THESE
RACIAL DISPARITIES OF COURSE
EXIST AT ALMOST ALL LEVELS
EDUCATION CRIMINAL JUSTICE
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS ETCETERA.
AND THESE DISPARITIES EXIST TO
LAWS IN STATE SANCTIONED FORMS
OF EXPLOITATION OVER HISTORY
SUCH AS SLAVERY SEGREGATION
SHARECROPPING REDLINING
MANDATORY MINIMUMS SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS. YES SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS MORE NOT GOOD
HISTORY FOR CARINO AND MANY
MORE WE CAN'T JUST OCCASIONALLY
INVOKED THE NAMES OF CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADERS FOR BLACK ICONS
INCLUDING FOR DOING SOMETHING
OF COURSE MOST EVERYONE HERE
KNOWS THAT WE NEED TO BE
AFFIRMATIVE IN THE ACTIONS WE
TAKE. TO WRITE MANY OF THESE
WRONGS IF WE GENERALLY WANT TO
HONOR BLACK HISTORY. I
PERSONALLY FIND IT DISTURBING.
THAT EVERY YEAR. IN ONE SENSE
OF COURSE APPROPRIATELY ON THE
FOURTH OF JULY.WE US BLACK
AMERICANS TO JOIN WITH US IN
CELEBRATING THE DECLARATION.
THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL
NINETY YEARS BEFORE BLACK
AMERICANS WERE PHYSICALLY
EMANCIPATED IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND WE SOLD SHORT AN UNDERSTATE.
THEY'RE VERY EMANCIPATION ON
JUNE EIGHTEENTH JUST TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THAT EVERY YEAR
COLLEAGUES IS WITH THIS
UNDERSTANDING OF MINE THAT I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. C. R.
TEN THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK. BETTER NIELSEN. I'M
NOT A PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE. I'D LIKE
TO MAKE THIS TECHNOLOGY AT A
BLACK HISTORY MONTH A VERY
PERSONAL. ONE A LONG TIME
EMPLOYEE. OF THE STATE SENATE
BRENDA JONES WORK FOR MANY
YEARS HERE FOR SENATOR DIANNE
WATSON CENTER TO WATCH AND I
WILL ACTED THE SAME YEAR. I MET
BRENDA THAT YEAR. MANY YEARS
LATER. I WALKED MY DAUGHTER
EMAIL DOWN THE AISLE TO MARRY
HER SON WILLIS PAUL JONES. AND
THEY BROUGHT A FIRST IN THE
WORLD LOGIN JONES. THE LOGAN
FAMILY WERE VERY PROMINENT IN
THE QUE QUE THE L. A. INYO
COUNTY. A VERY ACCOMPLISHED
FAMILY. IT WAS MY PLEASURE. TO
BE A PART OF THAT FAMILY AND
HAVE THEM BE A PART OF MINE.
AND THEY HAVE MADE THEIR OWN
CONTRIBUTIONS. IN LIFE. WILLIS
THEY'RE STILL PRODUCING AND
PRODUCTIVE. A GOOD FATHER NOT
YET A GRANDFATHER. AND OF
COURSE TOTAL GRANDDAUGHTER
LOGAN IS ALSO A DELIGHT OUR
LINE. AND THAT THERE BRING
STOOD THERE. NICE FOR HISTORY
MONTH FROM A VERY PER PERSON.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM I AND SO OF S. R. T. AND
I WERE TO THANK COLLEAGUE AS
WELL FROM. FOR- BRINGING
FORWARD IN AND SO WONDERFULLY
ABOUT THE CAMINO AND SOMETHING
THAT I CERTAINLY SUPPORT I A
VERY STRONG- BLACK COMMUNITY IN
LONG BEACH THAT HE AND I BOTH
SHARE- ONE PERSON I HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT BE REMISS IF I
DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE HER IS
DOCTOR NEEDS TO DAVIS SHE'S OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR IN THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH SHE WROTE
ABOUT RACISM AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE. AND THEN HER OPERATE AT
I'LL JUST SAY BRIEFLY SHEEP SHE
MENTIONS AND THERE ARE STILL SO
MANY WAYS AMERICA SAYS YOU
DON'T MATTER TO AFRICAN
AMERICANS TODAY HIGHER SCHOOL
RATES OF SUSPENSIONS UNSAFE
DRINKING WATER POLICE BRUTALITY
CONFEDERATE FLAGS MASS
INCARCERATION THE LIST GOES ON
AND WE'RE TOLD OVER AND OVER
NOT TO MAKE A FUSS BE HAPPY
YOU'RE HERE I WANT TO SAY TODAY
THAT I AM HAPPY THAT SHE'S HERE-JUST LAST WEEK SHE HELD A
MOBILE CLINIC IN OUR BLACK
COMMUNITY. AND ALIGNMENT WITH
THE N. DOUBLE ACP TO ENSURE
THAT SHE'S MEETING THE BLACK
COMMUNITY WHERE IT'S AT AND TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
VACCINATED AND THAT THRE IS
EQUITY AND I KNOW THAT- HER
WORK WILL LAST ON BEYOND
FEBRUARY AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE HER I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
REMARKABLE- ACHIEVEMENTS OF OUR
BLACK COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND I
HOPE WE KNOW THAT BLACK LIVES
MATTER. EVEN FAR BEYOND
FEBRUARY. SEEING NO FOR.
DISCUSS OR- CENTER BRADFORD YOU
MAKE INCLUDE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
RISEN TO DATE TO ADD THEIR
VOICE TO THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
OF RECOGNIZING AMERICAN HISTORY.
DEFINE TODAY AS BLACK HISTORY
AND I WANT TO QUICKLY RUN
THROUGH SOME OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT I WANT TO ASK YOU TO
REMEMBER ONCE YOU LEAVE TODAY.
BUT AS THE OLD FOLKS SAY WE
COULD BE HERE TO THE COWS CAME
HOME. THAT WE LISTED ALL THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO THIS
COUNTRY. WE STAND IN THIS OF
BLIGHTED CHAMBER TODAY BECAUSE
OF THE INVENTION OF THE LIGHT
BULB SO LET'S THINK LEWIS
LATIMER. WE TRAVEL NOW ON
ELECTRIC TRAINS AND BUSES
BECAUSE OF THE VETERAN OF
ELECTRIC TROLLEY BY ALBERT
ROBERTSON. WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO PUT OUR FOOD IN
REFRIGERATORS BECAUSE OF MR
STARK. AND WE CAN BOARD
ELEVATOR AND A SEND UP A
SKYSCRAPER IN A MATTER OF
SECONDS BECAUSE OF ALEXANDER
MILES. AND WE CAN HEAR HOME
WHAT A FURNACE BECAUSE OF
ALISON PARKER. AND AS WE
TRAVERSE THE STREETS AND WE
REACH INTERSECTIONS AND SAFETY
KNOWING THAT THE LIGHT TO
REGULATE TRAFFIC LET'S REMEMBER
DERRICK MORGAN. WHEN YOU REACH
FOR YOUR CELLPHONE TODAY. DON'T
BELIEVE THE LIE THAT A GUY
NAMED MARTY COOPER INVENTED TO
CELL PHONE IT WAS A BLACK MAN
BY THE NAME OF HENRY SAMPSON IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE NGUYEN VAN
IT'S A CELL PHONE. MISTER
COOPER ONLY MADE THE FIRST CALL
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE.
CONTINUE PRESS YOUR CLOTHES
TODAY. IF THOSE OF WHO ARE.
REMEMBER CEREMONY WHEN BENNETT.
DARN BOARD. IT FOR ALL OF US
WHO GREW UP WANTING TO BE
COWBOYS PLEASE NOTE THAT THAT
WAS A DEROGATORY TERM FOR BLACK
PANTS THE TERM CALL BOY DID NOT
COME INTO REAL ACCEPTANCE UNTIL
THE LATE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS AND
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES WE
START MAKING WESTERNS STARRING
TOM MIX AND WILLIAM S. HART.
BUT BLACKS WERE REFERRED AS
COWBOYS BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE A
FRIEND OR KNOW SOMEBODY WHO
STILL CALL GROWN **** MEN BOYS
SO THAT WAS A DEROGATORY TERM
FOR COWBOYS AND IF IT WASN'T
FOR THE LIVES AGAIN BUT
INDIVIDUALS LIKE JOHN WAYNE WE
WOULD SEE MORE BLACK COWBOYS
BECAUSE BIG LEAD TO CATTLE
DRIVES. HAVE YOU EVER WATCHED A
WESTERN UNION CITY CROSSING A
RIVER. THEY WANT TO BRING A
CALVET CROSS. THE TRUTH THE
BEEN TELL YOU HAVE SEEN IT AN
AMERICAN. BECAUSE THEY WERE THE
FOR ONE TO HIT THE CROSS THE
RIVER TO MAKE SURE WOULD SAY.
THEY WANT SYNDICATE. ACROSS THE
ROOM AND THAT BLACK PERSON
CROSSES FIRST. AND THEN IT MADE
OKAY FOR THE PALATABLE CROSS
BAILEY TO CHAU. AND FOR ALL OF
US WHO MIGHT HAVE UP WITH THE
LONG RANGER. THIS SPARKLY WHITE
GUY IT'S GREAT MATCH PATENTS
SURE WHAT IS WHITE STETSON WHAT
IS COMPARED. THE NEED AMERICAN.
WHAT IS MASS GONE. I HOPE IN
THE LORD YOU KNOW. THERE WAS A
REAL LONG RANGER BUT HIS NAME
WAS BASS REEVES IT WAS A RUN
AWAY SLAVE DURING THE CIVIL.
WAR WHO ESCAPED TO WHAT IS NOW
OR WHAT WAS THEN CALLED INDIAN
TERRITORY. MISTER REEVES WITH A
MASTER OF DISGUISE SO I GUESS
THAT'S WHY THE DAYS LONG RANGER
WAR MASS. HE WAS EXCELLENT
MARKSMEN. HE WAS A SKILLED
HORSEMEN AND YES HE HAD A
COMPANION THAT WAS NATIVE
AMERICAN AND HE WAS DEPUTIZED
AS A DEPUTY U. S. MARSHAL-
DURING A DURING THE LATE
NINETEEN SIXTIES ANY PROTECTED
TERRITORY THROUGHOUT. THE WEST
AND YES HE WROTE A SILVER HORSE.
OKAY SO EVEN WHEN YOU REPRESENT
US IN MOVIES AND TELEVISION YOU
APPROPRIATE ARE TRUE CULTURE
AND OUR TRUE STORY ANOTHER
EXAMPLE HIDDEN FIGURES THE
AMAZING STORY OF THESE THREE
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN. DOROTHY
VON CATHERINE JOHNSON A MERRY
WATER IN THAT MOVIE THERE'S A
SCENE A KEVIN COSTNER PLAYED
WHERE HE FED UP WITH THE STORMS
INTO THE FACILITY ANY SNATCHES
DOWN THE WHITE ONLY RESTROOM
SIGN. THAT NEVER HAPPENED. MRS
JOHNSON STATED I CONTINUE TO
USE THAT BATHROOM DESPITE ALL
THEIR COMPLAINTS THAT THE SIGN
WAS NEVER PULL IT DOWN ONLY
SURE THAT BECAUSE EVEN WHEN YOU
TELL OUR STORY YOU STILL HAVE
TO MAKE. A WHITE PERSON THE
HERO THEY STILL HAVE TO BE THE
PROTAGONIST WE CAN NEVER. HELLO
TRUE STORY TOLD EVEN IN THE-MOVIE GREENBUSH. WHEN YOU HAVE
DOCTOR CHENEY AMAZING.
PATTERSON TRAVEL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH THIS WHITE DRIVER
IT WAS AN EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONSHIP THEY WORK BUDDIES
YES THEY GOT ALONG FINE BUT IT
MADE A NEW MOVIE AS THIS DRIVER
WAS HIS HERO HIS GREAT
PROTECTOR IT DIDN'T HAPPEN. SO
I ASSISTED KNOW THE TROOPS
STORE AND THE NO ONE OF THE
AMAZING COLPOYS IN THIS COUNTRY
WAS A BLACK MAN BY THE NAME OF
BILL PICKETT. BILL PICKETT
CONSIDERED THE BEST CAL BOY TO
HAVE EVER LIVED. HE
PARTICIPATED IN RODEO ALL
AROUND THE WORLD BUT MANY TIMES
WHEN HE PARTICIPATED IN THESE
UNITED STATES HE HAD TO SAY HE
WAS A NATIVE AMERICAN IN ORDER
TO PARTICIPATE. AND I GREW UP
WITH THE NAME OF BILL PICKETT
IN MY HOME. AND I COULDN'T WRAP
MY HEAD AROUND BILL PICKETT
BECAUSE I'D NEVER SAW A BLACK
CAL BOYS GROWING UP. MY FATHER.
ON ME NO BILL PICKETT BE BILL
PICKETT WAS FROM MY FATHER'S
HOMETOWN OF TAYLOR TEXAS. THERE
IS NOW A MONUMENT PAYING
TRIBUTE THE BILL BAKER AND IF
IT WASN'T FOR A CONSTITUENT. IN
BERKELEY. BY THE NAME OF RULE.
I MEAN MOVEMENT MANSON WHO
START THE BILL PICKETT. RODEO
MANY OF US HERE WOULD NOT KNOW
THE NAY THE BILL PICKETT SO WE
THANK. I THANK HIM FOR THAT.
BUT AS WE HAVE LIKE INCLUDE. AS
WE ALL STRUGGLE TO GET
VACCINATED. DURING THIS
HORRIBLE PANDEMIC. IT'S NOT TOO
LATE IT FROM THIS DISEASE I
ACTUALLY REMEMBER THE NAME.
WELL ON THIS MONTH'S. HE WAS A
SLAVE WHO WAS BROUGHT TO THIS
COUNTRY IN SEVENTEEN OH TWO. HE
WAS BOUGHT BY. A PURITAN CHURCH
CONGREGATION AND GIVEN TO. AS A
GIFT TO THE PASTOR PASTOR.
OTHERS IN BOSTON IN THIS ****
ED GREAT DISDAIN FOR ILLNESS
AND MISS HE DIDN'T TRUST THEM.
BECAUSE HE WAS TOO SMART. HE
CONSIDERED HIM YOU KNOW WHAT TO
SAY WHEN YOU'RE BLACK AND YOU
TO SMARTER UPDATE YOUR THIS
YEAR THAT AND HE THOUGHT IF YOU
TOO SMART TOO WERE CONNIVING TO
DO SOMETHING. WELL IN. NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN TWENTY
ONE. A SMALL POX. PANDEMIC
BROKE OUT. ON THIS IN THIS
SHARED WITH BREVIN MATH THERE'S
A TECHNIQUE THAT THEY HAD BEEN
USING IN AFRICA FOR OVER TWO
HUNDRED YEARS TO INOCULATE
PEOPLE FROM DISEASE. THE
PASSWORD SO. AND BROUGHT IN
EXCITED ABOUT IT HE BROUGHT IN
A- THE TOWN DOCTOR IN BOSTON.
AND ON THIS IMAGE TRAINED AT
THE DOCTOR AND HOW TO INOCULATE
THE POPULATION AND BOSTON.
PEOPLE SO OUTRAGED SUCH A
RADICAL APPROACH THAT THEIR
LIVES WERE THREATENED. THEY
WERE EVEN THINKING ABOUT
LEAVING TOWN. BUT ONCE
INOCULATED QUICKLY LEARN THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT DELAYED IT
LISTEN 2% BY. AND THE PEOPLE
WHO WEREN'T LOCKED MACULATUS.
MORE THAN 50% DIE SO WHEN YOU
OR YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS. RECEIVE
YOUR SHOT DON'T JUST THANK GOD
THANK THAT. AFRICAN SLAVE FOR
ONE OF THOSE S. HOLE COUNTRIES
FOR HIS INGENUITY THAT HE
BROUGHT TO AMERICA AND
INTRODUCED TO THE WORLD. AND I
WILL CONCLUDE. WHAT SHE COOKING
WE HAVE SOME AMAZING COOKS AND
IT'S A LEGISLATURE WE'VE
EXPERIENCED A BRAT. FROM OUR
COLLEGE STOCKTON WE'VE HAD
AMAZING MEATLOAF FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOCKING OUT OF
FLINT RIDGE WE SHIP FIVE POPEYE
MADE BY A- FROM MY AND SAY DID.
AND I'M WAITING FOR THE PIES
FROM OUR PROTEA. BUT MANY OF
THEM HAVE BEEN ENCOURAGED IN
THE YOU KNOW TRAINED WATCHING
WHAT HAS NOW BECOME. CELEBRITY
CHEFS THE FIRST TWO CELEBRITY
CHEFS IN THIS COUNTRY WHERE
AFRICAN SLAVES ONE BY THE NAME
OF HERCULES WHO BELONG TO
GEORGE WASHINGTON AND DESPITE
HAVING A MALL FULL WOULDN'T
FALL STEVE GEORGE WASHINGTON
APPRECIATED A GOOD MAIL. THE
OTHER WAS JAMES HEMINGS. WHO
BELONGED TO THOMAS JEFFERSON
BUT WAS TRAINED BY THE BEST
CHEFS IN FRANCE. ONLY TO COME
BACK HERE AND INTRODUCE TO
AMERICA. FRENCH FRIES MACARONI
CHEESE CREAM BOY AN ICE CREAM.
AND PLEASE NOTE IF YOU LIKE
SOUTHERN FULL. IF YOU LIKE ANY
GOOD EVENING PLEASE UNDERSTAND
FOR THE FIRST THREE HUNDRED
YEARS ALL HE COOKS IN THIS
COUNTRY WHETHER THEY WERE CALL
CHEF TO COOK FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. WHETHER FROM THE
PLANTATION TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO THE HOMES OF THE RICH AND
FAMOUS FOR YOUR HOTEL TO
RESTAURANTS THEY WERE BLACK
PEOPLE. FOR THE RECIPES THAT WE
ENJOY THE DAY IF YOU'VE EVER
HAD A MEAL WITH PEANUTS IN IT.
OPRAH ALL RIGHTS. THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN RICE IS NOT INDIGENOUS
TO AMERICA AFRICAN BROUGHT RICE
AND OVER TO THIS COUNTRY. ANY
INTRODUCED ME TO A LOT OF
DELIGHTFUL DISHES WHEN YOU
ENJOY A BOWL OF GUMBO. IT
DIDN'T ORIGINATE IN NEW
ORLEANS. IT ORIGINATED IN WEST
AFRICA. AND WHEN YOU ENJOY A
BOWL OF JAMBALAYA IT'S A AFTER
THIS CALL JONES SO LET'S KNOW
OUR HISTORY THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE ETHNIC
STUDIES I HOPE WE SUPPORT
ETHNIC STUDIES BUT ALSO I WANT
TO THANK THE PRO TEMPORE
APPOINTED ME TO THE REPARATIONS
COMMITTEE. BECAUSE I HOPE WE
ALSO LOOK HISTORICALLY AT THE
PROPERTY THAT WAS STOLEN FROM
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND WHEN THE
FIRST PIECES I'M GONNA LOOK AT
IS BROUGH SPEECH IN MANHATTAN
BEACH A PROPERTY THAT BELONGED
TO AFRICAN AMERICANS. CHARLES
AND WILLIAM BROUGH BRUCE THE
BOUGHT THIS PROPERTY IN
NINETEEN TWELVE BUT DUE TO KEEP
THE KKK AND OTHER RACES SINCE
ACTIVITIES THEY WERE RUN UP
THEIR PROPERTY IN THE TWENTIES
UNDER THE GUISE OF BUILDING A
PART. BILLION BILL THAT PART
UNTIL ALMOST FORTY YEARS AFTER
TAKING THE PROPERTY FROM THE
BRUCE FAMILY BECAUSE THEY WERE
FEARFUL OF A LAWSUIT. I THINK
WE OUGHT. TO THE BRUCE FAMILY
AS WE OUGHT TO. HUNTER IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHO WERE WRONGLY STOLEN OF
THEIR PROPERTY. OF THEIR
HERITAGE OF THEIR RELIGION. OF
THEIR REYES I ACTUALLY TODAY
TO. I UNDERSTAND NOT ONLY GOOD
BUT THE BACK OF OUR AMERICAN
HISTORY I ASKED FOR MY
COLLEAGUES FROM PORTUGAL TO
SHARE WITH YOUR KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS AS WELL AS YOUR
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS THE
HORRORS THAT YOU INFLICTED ON
AFRICAN AMERICANS- TRANCE A
LETTER SLAVE TRADE TELL THE
TRUTH I HOPE YOU REALLY YOUR
ANCESTORS TREATED US FOR MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS FROM GREAT
BRITAIN. SPAIN FRANCE.
DATACENTER CHAIRED. TELL THE
TRUTH HOW YOU WILL IN AND
EAGERLY PARTICIPATED AND
PROFITED FROM THE SLAVE TRADE.
I DON'T SEE IT WAS SO LONG AGO
THAT IT DOESN'T MATTER. BECAUSE
THIS STATE THAT IS TO DO VALUE
MY EXISTENCE ON THIS FLOOR
TODAY. BECAUSE THAT SLAVE FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS AGO WAS JUST AS
MUCH OF A HUMAN AS I AM TODAY.
WE OWE IT TO OURSELVES THE KNOW
THE TRUTH WE OWE IT TO
OURSELVES THE RIGHT TO WRONG.
WE OWE IT TO OURSELVES TO
SUPPORT AFRICAN AMERICAN
HISTORY BECAUSE IT'S AMERICAN
HISTORY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS AYE
BAKER. GORGEOUS I BRADFORD HI
BYRON I CORTES THREE HI DALLY.
FIVE DODD. DORADO HI EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
HI HUESO FIVE HER TADO HI JONES
FIVE LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE MIN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN FIVE HOTEL
BOTH. I CAN FIVE PORTANTINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I AM
BURKE HI MY CAO SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK. HI I THIRTY THREE NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT MADAM PRO TEM
ATKINS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT S.
OR EXCUSE ME AT A HELP REMAIN
UNCLEAR COULD YOU PLEASE YES.
SENATE RESOLUTION NINE BY
SENATOR ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE
ELECTION OF MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES.
SENATOR THAT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU- MY APOLOGIES TO THE
CLERK- I RISE TO PRESENT A
CERTAIN ON WHICH CHANGES THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE AND SPECIFICALLY THIS
RESOLUTION APPOINT SENATOR
SHANNON GROVE TO THE COMMITTEE
TO REPLACE SENATOR SCOTT WILK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
OBJECTION TO THE UNANIMOUS
REFUSING THEIR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NINE FIVE THIRTY
THREE NO ZERO APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. WE ARE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM NUMBER. SIX
MADAM THIRTY THREE. ALLEN I
BACKER DODD. I THIRTY THREE NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. THE
DEPARTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ONTO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR EGGMAN. I TO ANNOUNCE
THAT THE BUDGET SUB HEARING
BUDGET SUB THREE ON HEALTH AND%
HUMAN SERVICES WILL START
IMMEDIATELY AFTER SESSION IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. VERY
GOOD. SENATOR NEWMAN THE SENATE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON THE
EMERGENCY PANDEMIC RESPONSE
WILL MEET TOMORROW MORNING AT
NINE AM IN THIS CHAMBER. VERY
GOOD SEEING NO FURTHER
ANNOUNCEMENTS. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THIS HURSDAY FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND NINE AM THANK YOU. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM.